le club de golf de candiac a fermé ses
portes en 2019 c'est maintenant un
promoteur immobilier qui en est
propriétaire
alors que plusieurs citoyens comme yves
couturier veulent à tout prix préserver
cet espace vert c'est de laisser un legs
aux générations futures parce que si on
commence à construire partout bas et en
europe une nature on n'aurait plus rien
il se réjouit du règlement adopté par la
communauté métropolitaine de montréal
qui bloquera tout développement sur six
terrains de golf celui de candiac
chambly beloeil rosemère terrebonne et
mascouche des terrains qui totalisent 2
184 hectares en milieu urbain ou des
espaces verts se font de plus en plus
rares cet espace là qui est un peu mieux
de la ville et un espace fort
intéressant pour nous la population a
clairement demandé d'en faire un parc de
conservation de les générations futures
alors non s'est engagé le conseil de
ville on accepter cette position-là à
beloeil même si le golf est toujours en
activité on ne veut pas prendre de
risque la golf 6 nous à beloeil était
prêt à 25% son espace pour la
construction résidentielle donc là on
est entré une voir est-ce que d'autres
alternatives deux options qu'on pourrait
proposer et qui permettrait de
pérenniser le sport mais aussi l'espace
vers les villes attendent avec
impatience la réforme de la loi sur
l'expropriation pour pouvoir payer la
valeur marchande des terrains qu'elle
souhaite préserver à l'heure actuelle
elles doivent verser aux dédommagements
qui équivaut à la valeur potentielle que
pourraient avoir intérêt s'il est
entièrement développé une facture salée
si le terrain en question appartient un
promoteur pour nous c'est inaccessible
on veut faire donc l'acquisition du
terrain alors ça sera une autre étape
qui va mener les maires réclament aussi
100 millions de dollars à québec pour
l'acquisition de terrains à protéger je
ne pense pas qu'ils aient tellement
d'objection à ce que est ce qu'on y
arrive on le verra dans le prochain
budget évidemment québec devra
maintenant approuver le règlement avant
qu'il n'entre en vigueur la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal indiquent
d'autres terrains de golf et d'autres
secteurs qui ont le potentiel d'être
reconverti en espaces verts seront
protégés ils se livraient bachar
radio-canada cardiaque